so chapter 8 is titled love Lutheran
tradition and that that's a good title
for me because in many ways Lutheran's
are pretty traditional even though
they're one of the early breakaway
denominations and what we call the
Protestant Reformation and this is this
is a section I always really like to
teach because there's so much going on
and there's so many different split of
us and distinctions these people really
thought that these distinctives mattered
a lot Martin Luther didn't do what he
did just you know out of blue he like I
said I can't but take a stand here
whether you will you you know white what
he said or don't like what he said
there's there's something to respect in
that and what we'll talk about that in a
moment now you notice that I've got like
I've been playing with a bit of color up
here and we get the Catholic Church and
then puts more arrows in the Protestant
Reformation these groups are all coming
from the Catholic Church specifically
from the Roman Catholic Church Martin
Luther starts out as a Catholic monk and
- tinium so he's within monastic life
the Anglicans started out as the
catholics in england the reformed
started out as catholics in france and
switzerland and it spreads to other
areas as well the Anabaptist started out
primarily in germany and some of the
peasant Catholics also also in
switzerland and they're all breaking
away from the roman catholic church and
they're doing it in different ways with
an emphasis there ended up being as many
distinctions between them these big
families as there are between them and
the Catholic Church over time you know
and I've got you notice I've got two
different colors of hair green and red
we could we didn't necessarily have to
pick
I just picked red because Anglicans are
usually associated with red and this is
what we want the wrong color the
Boscombe called the conservative
Reformation yeah and then in the studies
we often call this the radical
Reformation and why do we do that
because these two traditions retain more
from the Catholic matrix you just say
that they are if they were arising them
so these are liturgical traditions as a
matter of fact Anglicans that's kind of
up in the air they have two sacraments
or seven sacraments they actually
believe along with you know Catholics
and Lutheran's that the in the Eucharist
Christ is really present there's
different discussions about how this
takes place get a luther preferred
consubstantiation of transubstantiation
but if you look at these it's very hard
to tell much difference doctrinally
between them and so these churches
retained a lot more from the Catholic
Church that they were breaking a lot
from these churches are radically
different not only from the Roman
Catholic Church but also from these
other Protestants we'll see why they
would have a chapter specifically about
Calvinism John Calvin and the the
reformed tradition and then when we look
next class period at the end Baptists
one thing that you can say is that these
guys thought that these guys have gone
far and then there were also some cross
influences the reformed ended up
influencing some of the people in the
church
England who called the Puritans so
Puritans
are actually performed in the the
English church they fit into this
spectrum but on that diagram called the
independence so that would be you know
the Puritans or Congregationalists the
Baptist's a lot of people would like to
put the society of friends they're
slightly different the Quakers into that
they're coming out with somewhat
different experience but the you know
the radical reform whatever you do take
a really radical position you often
attract people who haven't gone that far
and so this actually sub splits within
the church in England that had some very
important historical consequences like
the Puritans coming to America at one
time actually the Pearson's took over
under Oliver Cromwell and after that
they kind of did get out of town let's
dig in this section we're looking at the
Lutheran's
but I wanted to give you an idea how all
these groups together so why do we call
them losers this is a pretty easy one
right yeah exactly
this is the guy who and like I said he
was a month and he book points out that
Martin Luther was very concerned with
questions about whether he was saved
enough yeah if you're a mom there
there's some things that do we didn't
talk about monasticism that much so I
should give you a little thumbnail
sketch of it here if you're a mom one of
the things that you're going to be doing
is a lot of Prayer
and some of the prayer might be by
yourself some of it will be
participating in the sacraments
you know usually daily Mass as part of
it and another thing that you'll be
doing is saying the Liturgy of the hours
which consists in this this cycle of
readings and Psalms and and songs like
you know canticles from the Bible that
are associated with these
the day so I'm gonna begin the day with
morning prayer and the day with comp
lying or you know the very last unit day
there's an evening prayer there's midday
prayers there's a lot of pretty going on
right yeah
Luther felt that he couldn't be sure
that he was saved and you know he didn't
originally because his original
experience doesn't really have anything
to do with indulgences as such we're
gonna talk about that in a moment it has
to do with this concern with what is
called justification when we talk about
being justified that means being saved
justified in the eyes of God and so you
know Luther is looking at the resources
of the church that he belongs to and
which is you know a pretty hardcore
member yet finding that they're not
they're not cutting it for it spiritual
or psychological sense so like your book
points out Luther is going to radically
diverge and emphasize these these three
your call of the three solos so if
you're not saved by participating in
sacraments like compassion and communion
and being baptized and being confirmed
and if you're not saved through saying a
lot of prayers throughout the day or
through you know giving alms or through
doing nice things for people smiling at
you know I mean because of the tonsil
that sometimes get given five people
during the day who don't expect it you
know right in their damp but that could
be a a work of mercy and Lutheran is
reacting against that sort of mentality
solo means didn't know that was a solo
game wasn't going to do a soul anyone
talking
exactly all night so three all these
or alone and book starts out talking
first of all about Sola gratia
so that means race and we'll talk about
that and just hurry up here so let's ta
okay and then one that's going to be
very momentous in its effect Sola
scriptura this is the path that Luther
thinks leads to salvation what she knows
Christians is something pretty important
right his one claim to be saved redeemed
where is one going to be one of the
Damned in the Reformation these are
really live issues Martin Luther is very
worried about this right now so release
we've talked about this a little bit
when we talked about Bertha dachshund
and Catholics grace means some sort of
divine action which somehow connects
with human beings it's something that's
given literally a gift to human beings
so for Martin Luther one is not saved
because God looks at you and says I like
that guy over there he does a lot of
good stuff
rather it's because God says I even
though I don't like that guy over there
God chooses to do so and you can't force
God's hand in any way it doesn't matter
how many works that you do it's God
alone calling the shots there were you
know quite a few people at the time were
saying things like well you know even if
you're not a particularly good guy you
could get into heaven by but I say
giving some money and then having some
massive set or buying indulgences or
giving giving to the poor why have
people do this to kind of swage their
conscience when they
you know worried about dying faith alone
[Music]
faith
again not networks is going to be
something for who Lutheran Lemon
Scripture Luther is reading acting
against remember when we talked about
Catholics and we had scripture and
tradition and magisteria this last class
period so Luther is saying Magisterium
in this case he's mostly talking about
the Pope really doesn't have any
authority tradition really doesn't have
any authority it's only the Bible if you
want to know what with Christianity
consistent you have to go back to the
Bible and actually the Luther like some
parts of the Bible much better than
others he called the the Epistle of
James the letter of James a letter of
straw he there were other other books
that he thought probably didn't deserve
to begin and didn't interview read he
was really focused on the Gospels the
story is about about Jesus Christ so
these are all key things your book also
talks about Martin Luther having this
this experience of the corruption of the
church he goes to Rome on a pilgrimage a
lot of people would do that in part
because it was sometimes you know told
to that by priests if you go on
pilgrimage you're going to be saved no
matter how bad of a guy you are going on
pilgrimage will remove your sins Luther
didn't believe that but he goes to Rome
because you know a lot of people were
we're doing that and what does he see
there your book talks about you know
secularism and corruption so think back
to your history classes what were some
of the some of the big problems of the
church at that time we're talking about
you know the beginning of the Protestant
Reformation the beginning of the modern
era what are some of the key issues yeah
that's a big so what's actually drawn
dividing right good stuff for looser
pants well it's got a little bit of time
talking about what is it indulgence in
just a moment but that's nothing that's
not everything right what were some
other problems that's one of the big
complaints yeah I'm giving him effort
that's okay what else do you remember
from your history classes you know there
was this notion you could save this that
there was an awful lot of road preaching
going on you know there are quite a few
things where official Catholic doctrine
would say this isn't culture this isn't
okay and there'd be people out there
saying things like yeah unless you
participate in this with this priest
you're not getting to heaven I mean that
was all over the map you know it was
those things weren't being reined in
there were some Catholics who were you
know saying remember Luther starts out
as a Catholic we're saying this is not
good we can't keep doing this sort of
thing we have to just stop that sort of
thing but what else what are some
problems with the actual crazy
themselves they were selling accurate
offices yeah what they call cemani that
means I want to be I want to be a priest
I go to you you're the bishop you know
I'm not particularly worthy guy but you
know the diocese always needs money
right so
I'd give you a nice big check and I'm a
priest and now I'll be a terror priest
woman and I'll do all sorts of bad
things and I won't preach very well and
I'll probably you talk about things like
you know priests having concubines by
that time in the West
priests were not supposed to be married
so a lot of priests would you have
somebody on the side this by the way you
know didn't stop with frost and
Reformation sometimes you know it
continued in other cases so he talked
about a lot of different forms of
corruption yeah the Council of Trent
really clamped down on this stuff but it
was good by that time I was really too
late a lot of people have left the
Catholic Church before these these
Protestant denominations let's talk
about indulgences now so when what do
you remember again from your history
classes about indulgences how are they
supposed to work in sort of popular
sense yeah you make a certain
contribution to the church like in this
case they talked about after building
campaign yeah piers and then it gets you
out of purgatory yeah so you guys
remember the discussion about purgatory
if you're not good enough to get like me
to heaven immediately because you saw
some stains of sin then you're stuck in
purgatory for a while and the way that a
lot of people imagined purgatory was you
know not a very fun place to be yeah so
what could get you out of purgatory well
you could like make up for here now so
how would you make up for ideally by
actually doing good things well you know
good things take a lot of time people
have busy schedules not everybody's up
to it wouldn't it be a lot easier just
to like pay for somebody else to do some
good things or just you know pay
directly and then it starts getting so
that's you know about about them and
then it starts getting a little bit you
know more confused and people start
saying things like well you know if you
sin you just you know buy your way out
of it by buying some indulgences and
there were people
they're selling indulgences and Hawking
them that way they were they're sort of
like the the online marketing scam of
the late Middle Ages if you want to
think about it that way
you know some of those things you
shouldn't click on because you know that
it's a bad idea but somebody does like
that that's the sort of thing that we're
talking about here where you look at in
your life man you should know better
than to think that that's the case but
there are people who do it and there are
there were many people at the time who
were buying indulgences and does it does
it strike you that the system can be
kind of unfair in ways that would go
contrary to the traditional Christian
message how could this be perceived as
unfair yeah a lot of people were giving
a little bit of money that they had for
for buying these indulgences it was very
predatory you know I mean the notion
that you could somehow buy your way to
heaven there should be people were
saying there's something wrong with that
and Martin Luther was one of the key
guys and so one of the key turning
points with respect to indulgences is
his ninety-five theses and this is what
gets everything go if you read the 95
theses he's actually pretty restrained
he doesn't say that purgatory doesn't
exist at that time he's got a view of it
as a more of a psychological thing he
doesn't contest that the Pope you know
ought to be Pope or anything like that
he says but the Pope can't give you
can't can't give you indulgences and
these people that are selling these
things they're really doing a disservice
and hope really if he's going to be you
know in charge of anything he ought to
be reigning these people in and he goes
into a sort of detailed theological
analysis of why this is a bad idea this
leads to a big split
and your book talks about him being you
know summoned to this this this
judgement in Augsburg and they want him
to say they wanted to recant and he
doesn't do it and quite a few Catholics
at the time are looking at this and
saying this is a big mistake indulgences
are a problem but those weren't the
Catholics who were prosecuting with
their meeting so now we get a split and
promise them you know originally is
meeting standing up against these sorts
of practices what happens with Luther is
he's stepping into a political situation
in Germany where a lot of the Germany at
that time is divided into all sorts of
little states you guys remember this
from here your modern European history
okay it's not until the 19th century
that Germany becomes one nation they're
there in this thing called the Holy
Roman Empire but it's a very loose
confederation the emperor doesn't have
much power and some of the states do
something some do others so some of the
some of the guys are in charge these
Kings these princes they say yeah I like
this Luther guy and we're gonna protect
him the elector of Saxony does that yeah
meanwhile there's no worth we don't
usually think about Sweden as being a
bunch of tough guys these days as being
like a major power but they were at that
time they were a huge military presence
throughout Europe and they were in a
unified Kingdom and they take up
Luther's claws as well and now you start
getting war between these different
these different groups eventually it's
being the lead to the 30 Years War but
you know before that we've got Luther
and his followers now starting to try to
do something new they didn't originally
intend to leave the Catholic Church they
originally wanted to reform it so you
know like a lot of this is gonna sound
kind of trivial but you ever get in an
argument with somebody
argument straights up being about some
things and real things but it gets a
little bit out of control and then
people like take a side and then you
know after a while you remember the
argument very differently about how it
began what it was about
and then of the two sides just can't
reconcile until maybe you get a third
party in there and unfortunately nobody
actually wrote anything down when you
were arguing you can think of it what's
going on here as a very high-level
instance of that so your book talks
about a lot of the changes that that
Luther mates and I'm going to run
through these very quickly so that I can
sort of remain on track
among these include translating the
Bible into German and what did that do
that allowed every person who could read
at least in Germany to have access to
the scriptures if really are saved
through Scripture alone if that's going
to provide the proper understanding of
things then this is the this is
democratizing religion it's it's no
longer in the hands of clergy to
interpret things it's in the hands of
everybody who can read in the
congregation not a Luthor did did
Germany didn't translate he did spend
all the time translating into French
English you know he was concentrating
where he lived he also adapted the mass
integer so that becomes putting a
vernacular the book also talks about
music and it's interesting Luther
himself wrote hymns
does anybody know were the most probably
the most famous Lutheran musician well
this will giving him classical composer
we don't usually listen to his masses or
requiems or things like that we listen
to his other things like Goldberg
Variations
is a baroque guy anybody know Bogg very
good yeah
johann sebastian bach was a Lutheran
composer
and why was he composing things because
they needed music they thought that
music was something that was really
central to Christian worship and they
didn't really change that much in the
mass you know Luther was was quite
conservative you thought you change the
things that need to be changed
everything else would leave it alone see
there was a great emphasis put on
preaching the word particularly the
Gospels and your book also talks about
the notion of location we've turned this
into a somewhat different term the older
sense of vocation means something
we use the term ecology that if you feel
like you have a calling to what it is
that you're studying in your major that
you feel you belong studying now if you
do that's great if not you know maybe
maybe it'll be lucky and have that sort
of thing happen hopefully you don't have
a calling to something not in their
major because then you're probably
taking the wrong classes vocation it
originally is understood as a calling to
do God's work within the framework of
your life so for me if I you know if I
was a Lutheran in this traditional sense
and a professor it would be to be the
best college professor I can be for the
greater glory of God for those who have
does anybody have CJ CJ anyone else in
CJ care you might be in it might be to
be the best police officer you can be
which would include other things like
being honest you know treating people
fairly bringing about justice where
we're injustice exists all of these are
understood as ways in which a person
could live out God's plan for them and
not have to be a monk or a nun
or priests not have to be within the
clergy which which had been the the
older way of looking at it
Lutheran churches like it's works about
don't generally have you know very tight
structure in the United States there's
the the largest ones would be the
Evangelical Lutheran Church in America
which is lost an offshoot recently the
Missouri Church Luthor Missouri yeah is
there a church Lutheran Senate Lutheran
Church Missouri said sorry yeah the
Wisconsin Evangelical Lutheran Synod
yeah
they each one of them is an association
of churches the local church is
affiliated with all these other churches
and and they're supposed to have the
same doctrine have the same sort of you
know basic structure to them but there's
a lot of latitude for for interpretation
and your book talks about liturgy I'm
going to tell you something for a
personal experience thing that'll put
this in perspective because it talks
about their book of worship and how
close it is to America to you know post
Vatican to Catholic stuff I grew up in
Wisconsin and I grew up in southeastern
Wisconsin out in the countryside so
there were a lot of Germans and then a
smattering of other people yeah almost
everybody that I knew as a kid either
their parents didn't practice any sort
of religion or they were presbyterian if
they lived in the town of Wales because
I lived near there
or they were Catholic related Lutheran
yeah and you could go to a Catholic
Church like if you had promised you know
your friends you hung out with your
friend and stayed over on a Saturday
night you go to church with them in the
morning and you couldn't really tell the
difference at that age between a
Lutheran Church and a Catholic Church
because the services were almost the
same the liturgical year address you
know that the minister or the priesthood
be worth would be
saying the lutheran church has had
eucharist less often that was the only
way to tell the difference for kids you
know you probably knew any better but
your book talks about that and that's
something very important that's part of
what we mean when we say the
conservative Reformation Lutheran held
on to a lot of Catholic practices and
traditions and that became part of the
fabric of their their you know their
their beautiful Lutheranism in the
United States is in certain respects an
ethnic religion a lot of Scandinavians a
lot of Germans in a few of the Baltic
countries Lutheran's predominated like
Estonia and Latvia you're not going to
find a lot of French Lutheran's you're
not going to find a lot of Spanish
Lutheran's so it got tied in with with
ethnic groupings and then that got tied
in with where those ethnicities went so
why why was Wisconsin a big place for
Lutheran's Minnesota is about two by the
way because a lot of Scandinavians and
Germans went there that's a very very
short process for the Lutheran tradition
keep that in your pocket for as we go
through things you want to know
something about who these these people
work now